it's about time you guys all showed up
hi i'm mika burton and we have got a lot
of ground to cover here in santo elaso
the new home of saints row we are about
to go on a deep dive on tons of all that
saints row customization has to offer
and we will also meet the devs so let's
jump in and get a better idea of what
saints row customization is all about
[Music]
saints row gives you the ultimate
freedom to express yourself in the weird
wild west you've never seen anything
like this before so buckle up out here
it's every boss for themselves
we're going to give you the lay of the
lag how to craft your perfect boss your
fleet of sweet rides your weapons your
crew and even your saints hq it's time
to build your criminal empire in style
people come to santo aliso from all over
because it's a place that bleeds
attitude here you do you
in saints row show off your personal
clothing style
from shirts pants shoes and hats to full
combos underwear overwear and even socks
[Music]
it all starts at the top
customize and style every hair on your
head down to your eyebrow color
anyone can build their entire look
around anything like skin control the
type texture tint gloss scars and even
muscle and vein definition
make both sides of yourself uniquely
different asymmetrical face
customization is a burst so smear on
some lipstick add ink clown out your
face or just act your age for once
oh yeah looking real mature in those
form-fitting undies hey working on it
it's about shaping the whole package
above and below
but it's not just the looks that kill
pick the voice that speaks to you and
flex your mood with emotes guaranteed to
provoke a reaction from the crowd
maybe not always the one you're looking
for but hey [ __ ] them right
the only way this could be better is if
you put on a [ __ ] shirt
[Music]
arrive in style with vehicle
customization
with over 80 rides to collect you'll
have plenty of time to kill in the
garage
go deep under the hood customizing all
your rides load up on exotic parts and
pieces modify that body change paint add
grime make that engine brown
and boom a whole new boss worthy
masterpiece
[Music]
wow all that and you won't even brag
about souping up your wheels
wheels like this
speak for themselves
boost performance with upgrade kits
acceleration nitro raw speed and make
your chariot battle ready
[Music]
go above and beyond with signature
abilities think boss worthy maneuvers
like crab steering make your own
wrecking ball or use ejector seats to
launch your success to new heights
you can look as slick as you want in
your customized ride all day but sooner
or later you're gonna need the perfect
weapon
change almost every aspect of your
weapons looks adjust the material
including the color on individual parts
change textures go glossy or metallic
make it rough or smooth
add decals too if you want and looks are
just skin deep right why not swap the
whole model want to pack that rpg into a
guitar case yeah i get the reference mr
mariachi
[Music]
your friends your saints your saints
vehicles they all gotta fit together
[Music]
tie the collective image into one
unified criminal masterpiece all right
listen up the church will become your go
to hq it's a real fixer-upper that you
can customize
as the saints grow in power
or dreaming one level higher head on up
to hq second floor where you can
mastermind all your criminal ventures
across the entire city
yeah looks like we can just agree to
disagree on who does boss better why
feeling overwhelmed by my outrageous
choice
a true boss is never overwhelmed oh we
can most definitely agree on that
[Music]
wow
that was a lot to take in all at once
but let's talk to the real rock stars
the devs about all this crazy
customization you guys just saw oh hey
volition team what's up
i
absolutely love the trailer but for me i
have to say it's raising a couple of
more questions than it's answering but i
say that as a total compliment so let's
start with player choice right what can
you tell me about it we have eight
different presets that you can choose
from and using those go straight into
the game or you can modify a little bit
to make it more of your own i love the
quick start elements of it because i
know for myself we know you dive into a
game we plan to spend about 60 plus
hours in it i want to spend time with
customization because you enjoy it but
you don't want to spend too much time in
it right the strength of going in and
just picking preset levels from a
starting point provides so many options
i want you to make me an instantly
recognizable face how do we go about
that sure we have a few preset options
here too we can make like a baby type of
face you can make a very recognizable
space in terms of the feature but what
would really be recognizable would be
you know a place that's half one way and
half the other like a truly asymmetrical
face when we go to some of the options
here we're going to the eye options
right now we're going to mess around
with the depth mess around the height a
little bit and you can start to see on
the left side of that face you start to
see the eye start to drop down a little
bit because like i said once you start
working with a face that is technically
two faces i feel that's truly
recognizable so there's a lot of options
to play around here comparing with the
eyes the ears the nose there's a lot of
different ways to really make a face
that's truly you know memorable for any
player absolutely and how do i customize
my hair i'm really hoping it's easier
than like in real life it's absolutely
easier than in real life there are
plenty of hairstyles to choose from all
different kinds of colors to choose from
as well and i really love the different
textures and styles of hair that we have
it's not just different cuts and lengths
but there are braids there's ponytails
there's a lot of different options to
choose from i love to hear all of that
my favorite detail face customization is
probably messing around with the eyes
and the cheeks i think that the eyes are
very expressive so i always like to mess
around with the heights and like the
different colors and even different
presets we have to show off different
contacts that show off the different
mesmerizing eyes trippy eyes all sorts
of things i really like our makeup and
our scars there's a lot of different
ways to make your character all the more
personalized and more custom to you and
what your boss looks like just by giving
them a really nice eyeliner look or
maybe a couple of battle scars
[Music]
you can make yourself whatever your idea
of awesome is with extensive body and
clothing customizations so guys what are
my options for sculpting my character's
physique can i choose the shape and size
what's actually possible here you have a
lot of possibilities when it comes to
changing your size and your physique
whether you want to look more like a
bodybuilder with cap delts and really
like striated quads you can do that if
you want to have a smoother look you
know you can you can do that you can
pretty much add the character with
however you want um and that that goes
for figure chest size uh growing size we
also have prosthetics so if you want to
have like like hand and leg prosthetics
you can customize your body that way
also that's pretty cool and you know
technically skin is one of the first
layers of outerwear so what can we do
there we can change skin tint we can
change texture there are plenty of
different shaders to choose from as you
play the game and progress and unlock
them so you can have broken glass or
galaxy to really maximize how unique you
look there are different colors as well
so if you wanted to be from the blue man
group you probably could be and what if
i wanted to express myself with some ink
can i get tattoos as well absolutely
we've got the whole body covered from
head to toe face neck arms legs chest
torso and back that's so cool and you
know the saying goes clothes do make the
person so let's dive into some outfits
head to toe customization with your
outfits you can have helmets you can
have hats you can put glasses on you can
have something across your face we
clearly brought back layered clothing so
please you can have a shirt with a
hoodie on top of that with a jacket over
top of that we really try to ramp up the
granularity that you can use in terms of
really editing your character's clothing
you can do whatever you want in this
game you have a lot of ways to really
express yourself in terms of clothing
that sounds phenomenal and i feel like
there's probably even more ways i can
express myself can you dive in a little
bit about those sure you can express
yourself with your voice i mean we have
you know eight different voice options
that range from series to kind of absurd
this game ain't gonna play itself and
there's also a whole bunch of emotes
that you can do to where you can have
like a touchdown celebration if you want
and just turn emotes where it actually
it modifies your walk cycle you could
have cleaned down the road you know
looking like people rather than do it in
a place you can actually walk down the
entire game and play that animation
and now a word from our sponsors
is that old reliable not so reliable no
more
oh it's got spirit all right but the
body can't keep up just ain't as rugged
as it used to be
now you can haul it off to the junky or
you can bring it on down to jim robs
where we'll give that beater a new lease
on life
maybe it just needs a new ticker or some
body work and a fresh coat of paint
whatever it takes our team's got the
goods and the know-how to give that
wreck a second shot
[Music]
because even an old car can learn new
tricks
at gym robs
[Music]
you can roll in style with one of the
deepest customization pools available in
the game vehicle customization you can
spend hours if you want in the garage
altering just about any part on your
sweet sweet rides
let's start with a curated collections
of vehicle add-ons with the presets we
have over 80 vehicles for players to
find collect and customize each of them
offer a preset which is a completed
combination of choices that radically
change the look of the vehicle with a
single click and paint is of obvious
interest here when it comes to car
customization how deep do those options
go we offer a wide variety of different
paint types i believe we actually have
six of them that you can pick from and
they range anywhere between a sleek mat
to iridescent pearlescent there are
plenty of months to choose from on your
car from your ornament hood to your back
trunk there are lots of different
bumpers you can choose from fenders
hoods you can even change your roof if
you wanted to you can even change up
just your side handles or you can even
make it settle if you want there are
tile profiles for days you can choose a
low profile tire a higher profile tire
you can change the axle height of your
wheels and you can also change the
hubcaps and you can modify these either
on individual axles or both at the same
time and how about the sound when i roll
up in my sweet ride the engine the horn
you have quite a few options when it
comes to the auto here you have
different options for the engine the one
and also your transmission if you want
to pull up with a really loud muscle car
sounding engine but you know you want to
bump a horn you know coming through like
you come from the clown circus or
whatever then you can do that it's just
so much fun to be able to drive around
and take nice pedestrians with my clown
car horn
and say i'd want to give my lift a
special lift if you know what i'm saying
any specialized equipment options
absolutely there's nitrous available for
your car so you can get that extra boost
to get away from the cops if you're on
the run there's off-road kits because
we're in a desert so there's going to be
a lot of driving out there there's also
a towing cable so you can connect your
car to different objects to take them
with you wherever you go you have
different upgrade kits that once you
fully level them up it will unlock a
special ability you can definitely
upgrade your car your speed performance
is durability you do have the ability
there in terms of an upgrade kit for all
vehicles and each each vehicle has a
unique upgrade here that includes all of
our water crafts we've got boats
hoverboard vtols helicopters all have
the same amount of customization choices
last thing on this widely expansive
topic let's talk a little bit about
signature abilities so you know when
you're trying to get away from the cops
whoever's chasing you you know you have
to make very sharp very specific terms
you can unlock an ability called craft
string so basically instead of sliding
around you take very small steps around
you really like corner precisely to help
get away from the cops yeah there's also
ball and chain you drag a giant metal
ball behind you which is great when
there's pursuit vehicles trying to stop
you as you swing it around and knock
them from being a threat my favorite one
is ejector seats because it means that
you can wing suit from virtually
anywhere so long as you have that
unlocked in your car there's also
kneecappers just in case people don't
know how to stay in their lanes while
you're driving or if you want an
additional boost to keep police from
rubbing into the side of your car you
can just keep hitting the infinite boost
button and just keep on going when you
finally unlock it and there's also some
story related ones that you will end up
seeing but we're not quite ready to
share that just yet so you'll have to
wait and see what those end up entailing
i know what you guys are all thinking
what about my piece right well we've got
tons of weaponry with tons of choice
over the aesthetics and with freedom
over where you can customize them you
should have no trouble finding that
special sidearm so how far can i go
changing material and colors you can
color any part of the gun that you want
from the body all the way down to
the minor parts well just like on cars i
kind of like stickers i want to put them
all over so what's available in the
decal department there are plenty of
decals available we have decals based on
the wild west or if you want to be
really fun and colorful there's also
really cool bright more fanciful
stickers i'm loving all of these details
for visual customization and i really
like how my weapon fires but i want to
100
change the look am i
asking too much there
you're not asking too much at all this
is actually one of my favorite features
in the game because you can actually
change how your weapon looks like for
example i know the rocket launcher
that's one of my favorite ones you can
turn that into a guitar case
there's also another one that i really
enjoy when it comes to the assault rifle
you can turn it's like an umbrella so
you think kind of thing that's like the
penguin like you know it's almost like
you have like oh an assault rifle that's
an umbrella like there's a potato cannon
think you could turn one of your the
melee bat the spike back into a pinata
bat so that's a fun one as well i really
like the cardboard weapons a lot those
are probably like my favorite ones we
have so many fun gimmicky weapons like
that in the game where when you shoot
the weapon or you use the weapon it
doesn't necessarily do what you would
expect a weapon to do there's some
really really cool gameplay elements
that unlock a lot of weapons that sort
of turn the combat on its head
[Music]
got the munchies
if you have the cash come try our stash
at chalupa cabra
santo ilesso's favorite monster food
truck
we'll hook you up with hit after hit a
farm fresh locally sourced product and
hard to find important delicacies you
won't find at those other food trucks
and we cook custom-made designer dishes
to order
chalupa cabra monster food
for a monster appetite
[Music]
so let's talk about the armory located
at the center of the church saints hq so
how does it compare to all those things
that i can do at say friendly fire the
hq has got a lot more convenient
locations to access things like their
weapons okay but what about my look can
i change my wardrobe here is this
different than using the style app you
can change your clothes just the same as
you could in the style app and you can
save all of these outfits as presets
that you can dress into any time this
place as we discussed before also comes
with a garage but what would jim robs
think of me taking my business here
instead of there yeah so really becomes
this active hub for choices before you
go back out and get to work yeah
anything that you've purchased from jim
robs will be available right at hq
throughout saints hq you'll find these
pedestals where it looks like it just
needs a little something you'll have
access to a variety of collectibles that
you can use to decorate your hq and you
can switch them out at any time and
there's so many to be discovered is
there a dress code here for my saints
you know i want to customize my crew
nobody's showing up in bathrobes right
only if you want them to you can have
them dress in a plethora of styles
different themes different aesthetics
you can set the dress code however you
want to not only that you can actually
set up all the vehicles that your crew
rolls up in so if you want them to roll
up maybe into a monster truck you can
have them do that well i can't wait to
roll up in a crew of a k-pop girl group
all dressed out in
pink diamond glittery boots it's going
to be phenomenal
please invite me i want to be part of
that absolutely
yeah
i'm in yes i have my crew
a feature of this game i really like is
that santo alesso keeps it real with
brick and mortar stores so where should
i explore those and how do those work so
you can actually find these brick and
mortar stores all around the city and
your map can help guide you there to
those different brick and more locations
you will see some old fan favorites such
as leather and lace but you'll also find
you have plenty of new ones to discover
as well there's also another pop-up shop
that is rojay's favorite which is both
the spakutas
and it sells these boots that have these
boot tips that go really far up and they
have cobra shapes
given that this is hq it seems like the
perfect place to mastermind i don't know
if i'm getting too off topic but while i
have you lovely devs here
what is up with the second floor
so you've found the criminal empire
table which is the saints war map for
expanding across the city now criminal
ventures the feature accessible here
isn't necessarily customization but
there's a lot of choices to be made what
venture you're going to build and where
you're going to build it 14 different
locations to expand upon and as you
build across the city you're going to
shape this the city landscape with your
choices we've gone over a lot today all
these customization features and i know
that saints row is a huge game i mean i
saw that map my god the amount of hours
that we will be spending in this game
but i have to know over everything
what is you guys's favorite extra or
low-key feature we maybe didn't get to
talk about today i love that we don't
have anything specific you can hide the
nudity in the game or you can choose not
to and you can choose to block that i
love messing around with the food trucks
i like really personalizing to more of
my style and look at that you can put
the you put the tacos on top of the
weenie truck
it's just so much to do suntans are one
of my favorite choices in the skin
selections they always make me laugh
we've already gone through so many cool
customization features today and it was
really awesome taking a deep dive on
saints row with you guys i know you're
so hard working on something new so is
there anything we should be on the
lookout for as fans i know everybody
wants to dive in and play with these
tools create their perfect boss but what
i can confirm is that something is
coming out that will let you do that
create your own boss express yourself
and that'll all happen before the game
releases on august 23rd
so just look forward to hearing more
from our socials and from sainsbury.com
just to get the opportunity to possibly
play with these tools
[Music]
well if you're like me you guys are
already packing your bags for santa
alesso and you know what while we're
here i just want to give a huge shout
out of thanks to brian traficante
danielle benthin kenzie lindgren and
roger smith for taking me through this
weird wonderful wild west of
customization options in the new saints
row from serious to silly badass to
monstrously absurd to the wildly
unexpected one thing is for certain
you'll have all the tools you need to
make yourself truly self-made i'm mika
burton adios amigos
[Music]
you